[Music]
who loves Disney we do we do we made so
many Disney videos we absolutely have to
talk about some of the best Disney
connections and their theories our
number two and number one have gone
viral and they were even partially
confirmed by Disney animators if you're
new here make sure to subscribe to the
things and give our video a big thumbs
up now let's check out five Disney
princess connections you should have
noticed Moana and The Little Mermaid
let's start with a crazy tumblr theory
that actually makes a lot of sense
tumblr user aster Luna Nova brought up a
good point when they compared the plot
of Moana to the plot of the Little
Mermaid and found out they're actually
scarily similar to the point where
they're completely opposite from each
other we'll explain what we mean in a
second Moana is the daughter of a chief
that wants to go to the ocean on the
opposite side we have Ariel the daughter
of a king and she wants to go on land
see the plots well it gets even more
familiar both movies have scary ladies
in the Little Mermaid it's Ursula but in
Moana to Fiji can look pretty scary too
both movies also feature a magical
necklace with spirals both even have
crabs have happened to be complete
opposite of each other it gets even
weirder have you ever noticed that in
the Little Mermaid a human sings about
eating a crab and in Milan
crap seems about eating a human even the
endings share a similarity in moaña
the hero returns home and reunites with
her family and the Little Mermaid Ariel
leaves her family to begin her adventure
isn't it crazy that these two Disney
Princesses share such a weird opposite
connection don't worry we have more Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs and tangled
this connection might be just a theory
but wait until you hear all of it
Disney has established that tangled was
based somewhere in Germany and Disney
theorists have determined Snow White was
based in southern Germany the fan also
pointed out that both Mother Gothel and
the Evil Queen where apply ops which is
a medieval style dress it wouldn't make
sense for the Evil Queen to wear this
dress since Snow White's time period
doesn't correspond to the period when
blades was a popular choice of clothing
the fan goes on explaining that Mother
Gothel and the Evil Queen share many
more similarities and claims they're
actually the same person according to
the theory the Evil Queen just faked her
own death since her body is never seen
and became Mother Gothel the similar
clothes the similar personalities could
be a connection between these two and
did you ever notice the bannister of
Rapunzel's tower has a painting of a
poison apple we always knew there was
something strange about Mother Gothel
but we never thought she could actually
be another Disney character what do you
think about this theory make sure to let
us know in the comments Beauty and the
Beast and Aladdin if you're a Disney fan
you're probably already familiar with
this one but do you know these two
movies have more than just one
connection Beauty and the Beast has
multiple connections to Aladdin most
people don't even notice but this
definitely becomes more obvious when you
watch the movies more than once and pay
attention to small details we all have
our favorite books and sodas Belle when
she goes to the book shop she starts
talking about her favorite novel she
talks about a prince in disguise
located in far-off places with daring
sword fights and magic spells those were
her words of choice not ours she also
describes the plot saying that the
princess meets her prince but doesn't
discover that it's him until a few
chapters after sounds familiar that's
not the only connection in Aladdin we
see Sultan's stacking up a bunch of toys
figurines if you pay attention to them
you'll notice that one of them is a
she'll eat beasts while the theory with
the book wasn't confirmed by Disney a
former animator did confirm that it
actually was abusive figurine a
coincidence or an actual shout-out you
decide frozen and tangled since frozen
is one of the modern Disney movies it
makes sense to be get inspired by other
movies that were equally as successful
we have no idea what we would do without
Disney fans who are actually able to
spot out all these details and come up
with these theories but in a weird twist
of events frozen actually paid a huge
homage to tangled and we bet most didn't
even realize it pay close attention to
the part in for the first time in
forever
we're onna opens the front door of the
castle on coronation day you can clearly
see Rapunzel and Eugene in the bottom
left corner casually walking in the
castle well there's an interesting
theory behind this some might say that
Rapunzel is actually on his cousin fan
theories states that the king and queen
of arendelle were actually on their way
to Rapunzel's wedding when their boat
sank
so Rapunzel and Eugene wanted to pay
their respect by attending Elsa's
coronation ceremony in a reddit post one
of the filmmakers did actually confirm
the king and queen did attend a wedding
however there has been no official
confirmation of the cousin theory but
the question remains why were Rapunzel
and Flynn at Elsa's coronation day if
there's nothing linking them to Elsa and
Anna Disney we want answers frozen and
Tarzan but tangled is not the only
connection out there the online world is
full of Disney theories and the
strangest some of them found most are
actually pretty believable although this
one is not official it is official in
Disney animators hearts as much as it is
in ours when frozen animators held a
reddit AMA they explained what happened
to Anna and Elsa's parents we already
found out that they were on their way to
a wedding but according to the animators
they didn't actually die at sea the king
and queen ended up getting washed up on
the shore of a jungle with their newborn
baby boy built a tree house within got
eaten by a leopard and yes this is
pretty much the plot of Tarzan the
animators said that in his head anna and
elsa are actually the older sisters of
tarzan talk about insane Disney
connections that bring together three
movies made in completely different
times this
is so big fans have even mapped out
locations of the two movies to make
sense of why the king and queen get
washed up so far away from their actual
location but then again Disney's storms
can be pretty aggressive anyways we'd
love to know what you think of these
crazy connections and if you have a
theory of your own write it in the
comments that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
hit that like button for more videos
like this one see you next time
[Music]